once complete in the summer poland's
wall will be 186 kilometers long almost
half the length of the border line with
belarus
will it stop almost daily attempts by
refugees and migrants to make the
illegal crossing probably not according
to a kurdish immigration lawyer who
spoke to al jazeera especially if as
he's widely alleged they continue to get
help from belarusian border guards
actually i think that the whole is not
is not useful we know that migrants
can't find another way and maybe as you
know as i told you that
san gardis helped them to cross the
border and of course they find another
place ragaz put us in touch with nizar a
kurdish refugee who with his family
including young children is among
hundreds living in a warehouse on the
belarusian side i asked nizar if he was
aware that poland is building a wall to
keep people like him out
what can we do we have to wait we can't
go back to our country
we're not part of the political problem
between belarus and poland we just want
to cross the border and get to safety in
the european union
it's a familiar story told by desperate
people fleeing circumstances they can no
longer tolerate
they may be among them purely economic
migrants as well but poland makes little
distinction putting hundreds into asylum
detention camps and simply pushing
others back
the crisis that flared last autumn is
now much reduced thousands were
allegedly lured to the belarus border on
the false promise of an easy crossing it
was both a cynical attempt by belarus to
destabilize parts of the eu
and also a political opportunity for the
polish government
poland's wall being built at vast
expense and partly through forests that
are a unesco protected world heritage
site is a pretty extraordinary answer to
what is now a fairly minimal problem is
it worth it to stop small numbers of
people trying to cross the border from
belarus well it is if you're a
right-wing populist government
state-run tv news bulletins report the
broadly popular claim that poland is
doing its bit to protect the external
borders of the eu from uncontrolled
migration
public opposition to the government's
policies does exist
we just would like to
to let people know that maybe not
everyone in poland is against people
coming here
from other parts of the world and
we are still here for them
but their voices are barely heard
jonah al jazeera in eastern poland